you've lived your life in a country that
is at war with the world how low would
you have to go to save your
four-year-old sister from certain death
while your friends and neighbors are
getting burned alive from fire bombs
you're going to have to be willing to do
anything in order to survive I'm going
to break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat famine and War
in grave of the fireflies this kid is
going to regret ever being born SATA
here is your typical Japanese military
brat who quickly reacts to the worst
news he'll ever hear Japan is about to
be bombed to hell and the air Sirens
blare everywhere around him and people
start to panic he Bears his family's
emergency supply of food while his
mother gets his little sister here ready
to go to the bomb shelter the mother
tells SATA that she'll go save them a
seat in the bunker while he secures the
house and tells him to watch his little
sister setsuko seita gets a hold of his
adorable little sister and grabs the
last of his things right as the sirens
blast one final time and that's when
they hear it the air around them fills
with the sound of thousands of whistles
falling from the sky to head outside and
look up seeing the end of their lives
headed straight for them it's a wave of
bombs a fiery Hellstorm erupts around
them while they take cover coming out a
second time to check and see if the
coast is clear but that's when
everything around them blows up in
Flames turning their little town into
literal hell on Earth people lose their
minds and begin to panic and begin
running left and right through the
streets SATA takes setsuko down to the
beach seeing the absolute Carnage and
death at the distance exhausted he finds
a sewer drain to take Sheltering while
they catch their breath okay this is
really really really bad my hometown has
just gone from peaceful and cute and
cuddly to literal hell on Earth the
world is at War and now we're being
invaded based on some of the signs like
the announcement of the incoming air
raid and sata's preparation of emergency
food underground it's clear they knew
this was coming and would have likely
already been informed of the next steps
to take but that doesn't make this
situation any less terrifying enemy
planes have begun to firebomb the cities
of Japan it means that unlike regular
high explosive bombs the power and
appeal of a firebomb is that their
structuring can actually have an even
greater impact on cities than a regular
bomb could ever have because as long as
it hits something flammable the fire
will spread and the destruction will
spread even further into areas outside
of the bombing Zone and our mom why
didn't she take us with her now we're
all alone with a cute but totally
useless toddler that can't help us for
[__] now I like taking naps in a good
tour as much as the next guy but these
kids using the sewers to hide in in
theory sounds like a great plan but it
could actually be their worst move if
they don't want to die a horrible death
because while hiding underground could
prove to be useful not knowing the
layout of it means that they're going
into this thing totally blind and from
the Air Raids happening all around us
it's very possible that our Town's area
utilities have been taken out such as
the water supply and gas Mains and that
means that the idea of trying to hide
out are possibly even worse find their
way through the sewers that could be
full of potential leaked gas and has the
possibilities of flood is a terrible
idea because we have to remember that
we're traveling with a child that being
said by running to the beach we've
accidentally figured out that the
firebombing is centered largely in the
urban areas of the city look at this
right here you'll notice that while the
city itself is engulfed in flames the
coastlines are fine for now this means
that our best bet would be to not stay
here but to evacuate from this heavily
populated urban area which is a prime
target for these fire bombs by using the
coastline to travel on for as long as we
can preferably migrating to the nearby
Villages and less populated areas while
we figure out our next step as long as
smoke inhalation is not an issue seeing
that the coast is clear they go to check
out the damage setsuko wants her mommy
and SATA tells her that she'll likely
find them at the Nippon Matsu station
the two then head off their war-torn
City desperate to find their mother the
corpses begin piling up everywhere they
turn and SATA hears an announcement from
the military everyone's still alive must
head back to the nearby school for first
aid and to regroup setsugo's eyes then
begin to hurt from the rain all the ash
in the air has begun to pollute the
clouds above them SATA takes her to the
school to get some help there they run
into this lady a family friend of their
mother she tells SATA the worst news of
all his mother has been critically
injured and is covered in second and
third degree burns all over her body the
doctor gives him her ring and he walks
him over to see his mother a wannabe
corpse the doctor tells SATA that she'll
die if she doesn't get to a proper
Hospital Satan reveals to the doctor
that his mother has a heart condition
and needs her medicine just to survive
making the situation even more desperate
and you want to know what the doctor
prescribed a dose of honkai star rail
this free to play RPG from hoyovers the
makers of gunshot impact will send you
on this out of this world experience
where you and your senses can embark on
immersive sci-fi Adventures made
acquaintances with captivating
backstories and save the world along the
way this RPG is for everyone to play
anytime and anywhere while enjoying the
star-studded voice cast with four
different languages on the go no problem
honkai star rail is a multi-platform
game that can be played on PC or mobile
so you'll never have to step off the
interstellar train called the astral
Express meet dozens of extraordinary
characters with magnificent outfits and
lifelike Expressions that suit your
unique personal style while you battle
through a universe that spans thousands
of years you'll never get bored board as
a Trailblazer you can journey through a
Sci-Fi world that's packed with in-game
lore and multiple Side Stories rally and
developed the combat skills of an
intimidating team to battle alongside of
expect orbital Cannon's ice walls
full-fledged armies and much more in
this alluring anime style RPG reach the
end of the universe and you'll be
rewarded with learning the truth about
yourself can't wait to join in on the
breathtaking adventure with beautiful
animations and music this RPG promises
then pre-register for honkai Star rail
using the link in the video's caption
thank you for our sponsor for today's
video Hong Kai star rail now back to the
depressing lives of SATA and setsuko
okay we're just a Skip and hop away from
being totally clinically insane this is
horrible our mommy your mommy has
officially become the worst mother of
the year sorry but it's true because at
this point staying in town has proven to
be a terrible idea but even if we have
to be with our mother let's face the
facts she's covered in second and third
degree burns and this is what makes it a
huge problem most can survive a second
degree burn affecting 70 of the body
area but few can survive a third degree
burn affecting 50 or more of the body
and our inept useless mother is likely
in a state of burn shock or her body's
vital tissues and organs are failing to
receive adequate blood flow and judging
by the uh incredibly high standards of
this hospital and this wannabe doctor
over here it's likely that she's not
going to survive much longer in this
state meaning that staying with her
mother is not going to do us any good
it's only going to be a matter of time
before vital supplies run out the doctor
already told SATA that they don't have
enough medical supplies here what do you
think is going to happen as the hours
roll on there's going to be nothing for
nobody because of this everyone around
us will soon get desperate because after
all desperate people can do terrible
things it is known by now that Japan
committed an act of War back on Pearl
Harbor and these Air Raids while
horrifying are just the beginning we
need to get out of here while there's
still time we already know that we
stashed some supplies back at our house
meaning that we can get to it while we
still can if I was say to I leave my
little sister in the care of that family
friend and head over to retrieve the
supply stash first and then I'm taking
my little sister and we're gonna leave
first thing in the morning leaving while
it's daylight will allow to check for
any more incoming Air Raids and will
allow us to look around for anything
useful that we may need for future
survival such as towels water food
possible medical supplies people are
going to figure out that there's no food
there's no medical supplies which means
we have to leave while the game's good
we gotta get out of Dodge and secure
better lodgings putting on a brave face
SATA goes back out to meet his sister
and gives her their mother's ring to
keep safe he tells her that their mother
is heading to a hospital in the area of
nishonomia and it just so happens that
their aunt lives in the same city and
will keep them safe while their mother
recovers but they do not realize that
this is the beginning of the end for
their entire family the two siblings
head to the town where their aunt lives
and they both get settled into their new
home and one day their aunt mentions how
nice their life must be since their
father is in the Navy a few days later
Satan returns to his war-torn village
and retrieves his family's emergency
ration of food finding a special gift
for setsuko a can full of candy he
brings back the supply food to his
aunt's house thinking that this food
will solve all of their problems forever
later the ant goes through sato's recent
food astonished at all the tasty Nom
Noms she tells SATA how lucky his family
must be to get Soldier privileges like
delicious great food during wartime she
then asks him if he's heard from his
mother but that's when sata's face
begins to quiver he tells her that his
mother died this afternoon while setsuko
was at school and tells the aunt not to
tell setsuko and she agrees but then she
also requests that he writes to his
father immediately over the next few
weeks Santa tries to bury his heartbreak
emotions and keeps setsuko happy taking
for a walk that night and showing her
the fireflies in their Garden he then
surprises her with her favorite treat
the last treat that she will ever get in
her life a fruit Drop candy the next day
the ant begins to get impatient with
SATA and his sister and asks if he's
heard from his father back in the Navy
but SATA tells her that his dad hasn't
written back yet and it's strange and
the Ant wonders what's going on later at
dinner they get word from the aunt's
husband that the future of the war is
beginning to look more and more hopeless
day by day factories are closing down
and food is becoming harder to find the
husband gets another Bowl full of
vegetables while SATA and septica only
get clear soup oh I hate that ant I know
we're in a horrible situation because
unlike evil monsters or death games this
situation is getting worse and worse by
the day we've now just heard Air Raids
all the way out here which means that
even in the countryside where it's
supposed to be safe we've basically
traveled from one dangerous hot spot to
another somehow these kids are still
able to get to the beach and back to
their aunt's house that is not far
enough folks you need to get farther
Inland that is not far enough and while
yes we found a stable-ish source of food
from our mean Crone of an ad we need to
pick up the size that this ad is
dropping down right now because she has
grown tired of keeping us here and now
she's only giving certain special foods
to her family members and tricking us
into selling our mother's clothes while
this could be looked as her simply
defending her own family over us either
way the outcome is the same we were not
meant to stay here for this long our
aunt was thinking that we would just
stay here for a few weeks and now we
could be here forever and again with
food being rationed tensions being high
people will only start to become more
desperate and look out for their own
people which me and my little sis sister
are not a part of in this house of hers
we can't go back we can't live out on
the streets we have to add value to this
household beyond our usual amount
because honestly up until this point
SATA really hasn't done much to help out
they need to start becoming invaluable
to this household from offering to do
chores that nobody wants to do
essentially becoming this ants little
slave while this will be lame as hell
you know it's Leslie not starving on the
streets with nowhere to go the next few
weeks SATA tries to shield septico from
the dead bodies quickly piling up and
they hear a word from around town that
the full-on invasion of Japan is
imminent SATA tries to remain calm but
satsuko slowly gets hungrier and
hungrier by the day the townsfolk began
to get even more desperate selling
whatever things they have to in order to
buy more food sata's Aunt goes ahead and
does the deed and sells their Dead
Mother's clothes and setsuko is forced
to watch all traces of her mother
disappear the days pass by and they
begin to run into the same problem again
no food the aunt gives her daughter and
husband rice while she tells SATA and
setsko that they are deserving of
something so viable anymore she scolds
them for being lazy and tells them that
they don't deserve as much as the people
working hard for their Nation during the
war what is her problem does she have
any Soul any heart at all her I'm fine
with you guys staying here tank has
clearly run out the war is getting worse
and supplies are dwindling and the Ant
is acting like a total D some would say
that she's acting like how anyone would
in times of desperation such as these
because unfortunately desperate times
tend to bring out the worst in people
trying to survive so that means I'm done
I'm gonna take my four-year-old little
sister and find someone else who has a
soul and a heart and is willing to take
us in I'm willing to work for food to
take care of my little sister so she
doesn't die I'm going to wait until the
next salary payment that the husband and
if possible the daughter received and
would either a steal the money if it was
placed inside the house along with the
remaining supplies before getting out of
Dodge with my little sister or B wait
until the family gets their next
paycheck of which they would use to buy
more supplies of food which we would
steal and run away during the middle of
the night when they're asleep we'll have
the food that we need that will be long
gone before they wake up still hungry
satsuko asks for more rice but the aunt
tells her that everything must now be
rationed she gets annoyed and casually
asks SATA if they have any other
relatives that they could stay with
because now they are running out of food
too knowing it's only a matter of time
SATA goes to the bank the next day and
takes out his mother's savings 7 000 Yen
he tells satsuko that now they'll be
able to live like kings giving her one
more fruit candy drop after they go buy
cookware and food for themselves and
enjoy the next week living it up but
soon rations of food get even more
expensive and their mother's money
quickly runs out even setsuko's fruit
candy gets finished to make her happy he
pours water into the container and makes
her fruit flavored water and his little
sister Savers every bit of what will be
the final treat that she ever has the
next day the ant breaks sata's final
straw and he leaves the house with
setsuko telling her that they'll get out
of her hair and this ant does nothing to
stop them from leaving SATA tells
setsuko that now they'll live in the air
raid shelter nearby where they'll be be
able to live freely and without any
worries or have to answer to anyone else
sounds Blissful but that was their
biggest mistake they get the supplies
for their new home and begin Scavenging
for goods and doing what they can to get
by even catching some fireflies that
night to light up their dark shelter the
next morning setsuko complains and asks
SATA why do all the young fireflies have
to die so soon crumbling apart inside
SATA ignores her and tries to keep his
composure thinking of his very crispy
dead mother and his missing father he is
now near his Breaking Point the days
passed by and their situation becomes
more hopeless they run out of things to
trade for food and the farmers have
nothing to spare anymore and the both of
them begin to get more and more hungry
this farmer knowing sata's Aunt tells
SATA to swallow his pride and return to
her but he refuses that night he gets
caught trying to steal his neighbor's
vegetables getting badly beaten in the
process before being sent to the police
station this cop lets him off of the
hook telling him that the food situation
will only get worse in Japan and that he
needs to find someone to take care of
him and his little sister the next day
SATA comes up with a plan and begins
raiding people's houses during the air
race running through the terrifying
fires and destruction in order to
retrieve food for his little sister but
he finds that no one has anything left
to offer he then heads home and lays
eyes on his sister who now can barely
stand up concerned he finally takes her
to the doctor but it's here that he
tells SATA that all setsuko needs is
food in order to get better live it
frustrated beyond belief say to demands
him where do they get food where is it
where can he find food he tells SATA
that he doesn't know and also tells SATA
that satsuko doesn't have much time left
okay this is crazy because right now the
situation is not good we're severely
underestimating the harsh realities of
our situation and now we're on the brink
the most terrifying part about all of
this is what our sisters complained of
and has now begun showing signs of
sickness rashes on the skin and to
diarrhea and they are common signs of
malnutrition and the doctor now just
confirmed it but even though we've been
eating what we could find it hasn't been
enough and given the fact that setsko is
below the age of seven that means her
immune system is even more fragile and
the signs showing up on her body means
that they are both deep in the third
phase of starvation where their fat
reserves have now been depleted and now
the body is eating its own muscle its
own protein to use is energy causing the
cell function within setsuko's body to
die we have hardly any time left to save
her Scavenging for food is not gonna
work we already tried that we need a
guaranteed steady supply of food and we
also need medicine both of which we do
not have the most logical thing we could
do in this situation would be to
desperately do everything in our power
to locate find and get to a Japanese
Monastery due to the very nature they're
very likely to be sympathetic to our
situation they will have food and they
have medicine to spare we don't have any
more time folks we have to do something
or our little sister is going to die
desperate he takes out the last of his
mother's savings and he hears from these
strangers that Japan has officially lost
the war he asks them if they know what
happened to the Navy and they tell him
that almost all of it has been destroyed
begins to panic and asks what happened
to his dad but no one knows anything and
he begins to realize the worst daddy
died moving on to feed he quickly heads
back home with more food but it's too
late he sees his sister lying like a
corpse and finds her hungrily chewing on
marbles she tells SATA that she's made
him some rice balls to eat but all he
sees in her hands are Stones terrified
for his sister he tells her that he's
going to quickly make her some food but
she stops him and thanks him for
everything he's done closing her eyes
she takes a nap SATA panics and quickly
rushes to go make some food not
realizing that satsuko will never wake
up next they Satan prepares for his
sister's cremation and later puts her
ashes in her favorite tin of fruit candy
and he decides to leave the shelter for
good a few weeks later a janitor finds
SATA malnourished and on the brink of
death and holding his sister in his
hands the janitor ignores him and takes
the fruit candy box leaving him to his
dark fate because he doth to the janitor
takes the fruit candy box and throws it
outside sachiko's ashes spill onto the
grass Awakening the fireflies nearby and
setsuko's spirit awakens playing around
on the grass and sits with SATA longing
for the day when she you can have her
fruit Drop candy once again
and I end up like food drop can I go and
I like